il rappelle son ambassadeur à rabat elle
reproche à la représentation
diplomatique marocaine à new york
d'avoir affiché publiquement son soutien
au droit à l'autodétermination la
kabylie en tout on retrouve tout de
suite notre correspondant bassem chez
bis bonsoir bassem la décision de
rapatrier son ambassadeur prend effet
immédiatement et d'autres mesures ne
sont pas exclues selon alger bonsoir ce
fut effectivement c'est une décision
assez graves et importantes d'un point
de vue diplomatique entre les deux pays
voisins et à la fois d'arrigo et celle
d'alger de rapatrier son ambassadeur qui
est située à rabat avec un effet
immédiat suite à cet événement la
semaine dernière c'était de la science
unis où la représentation au maroc n va
sont ignorés distribué un tract aux pays
membres de des pays acp n'ont aligné
dans ce tract on pouvait lire le soutien
du royaume de marque du maroc au peuple
kabyle à l'auto détermination un coup de
plus aux relations entre le maroc et
l'algérie à l'algérie qui a très mal
pris cette attaque le ministre des
affaires étrangères algérien même parlé
d'une trahison algérie condamne cet acte
de manière ferme alger parle même d'une
dérive dangereuse et deux pays sont même
au bord de la rupture diplomatique de
rien on sait très bien que ces deux pays
voisins et à la fois rivaux sont en
tension depuis des années des années son
fond du problème du sahara occidental le
ministre des affaires étrangères
algérien a même parlé d'un complot
dirigé contre l'unité à gérer c'était
des tensions qui sont palpables entre
ces deux pays une gravité de la
situation qui s'est passé de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique aux états unis
alger a promis que des mesures strictes
à naître prendre ils attendent que le
royaume du maroc se prononcer clarifie
la situation concernant ses positions en
attendant son ambassadeur et rapatrié à
alger alger avec la règle d'autres
mesures pourraient être prises si le
maroc ne clarifie pas la situation
n'importe pas d'excusés à ce qui s'est
passé à new york par sa délégation
merci beaucoup pour ces précisions
massai magelis